jk rowling describes dumbledore and
grindelwald's relationship as passionate
but was one of the world's darkest
wizards really capable of falling in
love
world where we wizards were free to live
openly
to love freely albus dumbledore's
relationship with gillard grindelwald is
one of the most
complex romances in the entire harry
potter universe
but there are still so many questions
about their love affair
left unanswered we know we can expect
these forbidden lovers to duel in one of
the upcoming fantastic beasts films but
we know
so little about how they get there their
blood pact may have signified an
unwillingness to become
enemies or was it really just
grindelwald's manipulation claiming
another victim
is there significance behind why they
didn't perform the unbreakable vow
and while jk rowling says their
relationship was passionate
is there any chance that we'll actually
get to dive deeper
into the romance in the final three
films dumbledore's
style dumbledore was born in 1881
and grew up in godric's hollow with his
sister ariana
and his brother aberforth grindelwald
was born around
1883 and while dumbledore was attending
hogwarts
he was studying at drumstrang institute
well
before he got expelled at the age of 16
for performing
twisted experiments we know that
dumbledore first met grindelwald after
experiencing a family tragedy
in 1899 dumbledore's mother became the
victim of an outburst from his sister
ariana
dumbledore returned to godric's hollow
to be with his family
and it's there that he met grindelwald
who was studying the deathly hallows
what is it well it's the sign of the
deathly hallows of course
dumbledore quickly became interested in
grindelwald's controversial ideas
which led to the two of them bonding
over the search for the hollows
their plan was to use them to become
unstoppable
from there they could overturn the
ministry and do what manipulative dark
wizards do
use their power to rule over muggles and
say it was all for the greater good
it was dumbledore's brother aberforth
who became concerned with dumbledore's
ambitions
though there's no evidence he knew that
romantic love was one of the reasons for
his brother's fascination with
grindelwald
aberfurth's suspicions resulted in a
three-way duel between aberfurth
dumbledore and grindelwald
and when ariana tried to interfere she
fell victim to a rogue curse
to whom the curse belonged is still
unknown but grindelwald
immediately fled while it's clear
dumbledore supported grindelwald's
message for a while
what is it exactly that caused him to
change his mind
of course there was the loss of his
sister as well as grindelwald's
willingness to fight dumbledore's
siblings in the first place
the duo likely showed dumbledore that
trust was broken between the two wizards
dumbledore probably viewed the duel as a
betrayal but grindelwald may have seen
dumbledore protecting his
family as a betrayal as well jk rowling
insists that there was a passionate
intimate side to the wizard's
relationship even calling it
incredibly intense but that in writing
she was a lot less concerned with that
and more focused on their emotional
journeys a lot of the emotional turmoil
is caught up in the fact that the two
wizards
once incredibly bonded were no longer
able to support each other's choices
when dumbledore sees grindelwald in the
mirror of aerosaid
it's clear that there's a deep longing
there it shows us our hearts deepest
desires
so there's no doubt that dumbledore
feels an unbreakable bond with the dark
wizard
dumbledore's admission that he and
grindelwald oh we were closer than
brothers
further confirms that grindelwald meant
a lot to him and his lie to harry about
seeing socks in the mirror
also points out that the bond is much
more than he'd like to admit
dumbledore's admission to harry about
seeing himself in grindelwald as young
leaders of the revolution
is definitely a part of the reason he
won't face him he feels he will be
tempted to join him if he lets himself
get too close
i cannot move against grindelwald it has
to be you
on the other hand he could be forced to
eliminate him which would make
dumbledore feel even worse so the blood
pact the two wizards made is not the
only thing keeping them apart
but it is symbolic of all these
emotional complications
the timing of the blood pact is unknown
but it's likely it was made before the
duel that took ariana
if that's the case then dumbledore might
also be running from his own
responsibility in facing grindelwald
again
and the possibility that the rogue curse
that claimed his sister was
actually his fault did he ever mention
my name
did he ever mention hers a blood pact is
a magically binding agreement that
involves two people cutting their hands
with their wands
interlacing them and making an oath two
glowing drops of blood rise from their
palms and become one
a vial forms around the drop enclosing
it and becomes almost impossible to
break
we know that in 1927 grindelwald
possessed the vial from his pact with
dumbledore
though we have no idea how long he had
it for grindelwald held onto it
to protect it from dumbledore attempting
to find a way to destroy it
that is until newt's niffler got its
paws on it the thing about the blood
pact is that while it meant that
dumbledore couldn't go against him
it also meant that grindelwald's hands
were tied the blood pact signifies
a lot of problems for the two wizards so
why didn't they use the unbreakable vow
the vow would have made it impossible
for one to move against the other
but the problem with the vow is that
it's very one-sided
there's an imbalance of power because
one person swears to the other to uphold
their promise or
face unbearable pain dumbledore and
grindelwald might have made a blood pact
because they truly care about each other
since both are equally bound to the oath
it suggests that they saw each other
as equals the two ultimately fight in a
legendary duel in 1945 when dumbledore
gains possession of the elder wand
as for how that became possible in the
crimes of grindelwald dumbledore says
that he may be able to destroy the vial
that binds them
can you destroy it maybe but it all
comes down to one question
were dumbledore and grindelwald really
in love with each other
in 2005 rowling said of dumbledore i see
him as isolated
and a few people have said to me rightly
i think that he is detached
we know eventually he defeats
grindelwald but we don't know how he
breaks the pact
we don't even know the words used in the
oath but from what we know of his
character
and what rowling has said about his
loneliness we know that whatever
dumbledore had with grindelwald
affected his entire life even after
finally defeating him
the teenager received a wound from which
dumbledore never recovered
there was definitely some love on his
side and he never truly forgot about
what he shared with grindelwald
on the other hand what we know of
grindelwald is decidedly
not loving he's incredibly powerful
easily manipulates people
and exploits their vulnerabilities he's
a mastermind in
all senses of the word it's possible
that grindelwald never felt
anything for dumbledore he just wanted
to take advantage of his mind and use
him to find the deathly hallows
at the end of the crimes of grindelwald
he even replaces one dumbledore
with another
still we can't deny that the two wizards
were very similar when they were young
they wanted to reshape the wizarding
world they thirsted for power
and they were both brilliant they
supported and understood each other
for grindelwald that might have been
love and keeping the blood pact could
have had sentimental value
along with practicality if dumbledore
had not changed his mind
perhaps they would have been the most
powerful dark wizards in history
and maybe they would have sincerely
loved each other through it all
grindelwald may still even admire
dumbledore after his defeat
when faced with voldemort he seems to
take some satisfaction in being able to
say that dumbledore has the elder wand
the elder wand lies with him
dumbledore with three movies left in the
series
there's hope that the romantic
relationship between the two powerful
wizards will become more obvious
jk rowling has teased the relationship a
lot but there's still
no explicit proof in any of the films
that it was romantic
what we find out might change everything
we think about their relationship but
for now
we can only speculate on the wizarding
world's most mysterious love affair
how do you think grindelwald really felt
about dumbledore
would you like to see a more personal
look at their relationship let us know
your thoughts in the comments
plus don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe to the things for
more
thanks for watching